[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je vous dis que je ne suis plus un
prof normal depuis cinq ans et que ma
classe est vraiment devenu bizarre ça
vous intrigue et si j'ajoute que ce qui
s'y passe entre les murs intéresse au
plus haut point les entreprises qui
m'appelle nos contacts et m'envoient des
mails presque tous les jours à ce sujet
alors là vous mourrez envie de savoir
bienvenue dans la classe renversé une
classe où les étudiants font tout et le
prof rien on ne leur donne aucun
document juste les titres des chapitres
charge à eux de tout faire charge à eux
d'écrire les chapitres de rechercher
l'information sur internet de la trier
avec discernement décrire ces chapitres
de les illustrer de trouver des films de
les annoter charge à eux de préparer les
interrogations les barèmes de distribuer
des copies de remplir des copies de
ramasser des copies de corriger des
copies de rendre les notes
le do it yourself faites tout par vous
même le rêve
cette casse existe depuis cinq ans elle
est expérimentale elle est complètement
transformé quand vous y entrer ça ne
ressemble à rien ou plutôt à une petite
entreprise une start-up une entreprise
qui fabriquerait de la connaissance
les étudiants arrivent à 8 heures du
matin les séances durent 2 à 3 heures il
n'y a aucune pause ils peuvent rentrer
et sortir comme il le désire s'organiser
comme ils le souhaitent
dans chaque équipe les étudiants qui
n'ont aucun document doivent travailler
avec leurs propres outils informatiques
tablettes téléphones numériques et même
des livres en papier
ils cherchent de l'information ils
doivent la référence est ce que n'aime
pas les bons élèves d'ailleurs ils
doivent aussi la publier sur une
plateforme collaborative et discuter
ensemble avec le professeur sauf qu'ils
produisent dans chaque équipe composée
de six
cet étudiant on a différencié différents
milieux niveau des bons élèves des
moyens et des élèves plutôt doué en
génétique selon le cas de manière à bien
les mixer que chaque équipe avance à la
même vitesse
il ya une véritable organisation entre
eux chacun prend ses responsabilités
responsable des textes d'une
iconographie contrôle publication sur la
plateforme mêmes discussions avec
l'enseignant qui n'a plus rien à faire
chaque jour 1 si c'est petit business
unit fabrique le contenu du cours
puisqu'ils n'ont plus de livres
les séances commencent toujours par des
exercices au nom bizarre cusems
intelligent interrogations inversée
karaoke ping pong battle tricherie
obligatoire et table au tournant les
tableaux tournant une méthode
expérimentée par ces étudiants
particulièrement efficace elle remplace
le cours magistral finalement sur un
temps de 15 minutes avant pour leur
expliquer un fondamental je leur disais
voilà écoutez moi bien je vais vous
expliquer quelque chose de vraiment très
important vous êtes presque sûr de
l'avoir à l'examen écoutez moi bien
et au bout d'un quart d'heure de mon
explication tout le monde avait oublié
ou presque ce que j'avais expliqué alors
que là je leur pose une question et il
travaille sur des tableaux il commence à
réfléchir à produire leurs réponses et
toutes les trois minutes il ya une
rotation qui fait que chaque groupe
continue de travail sur un schéma
commencer par un précédent ce qui fait
qu'au bout de dix minutes
j'obtiens six à sept tableaux différents
co-construit co écrit et nous n'avons
plus que quelques minutes à passer pour
vérifier ce qui est produit par les
étudiants ensemble et puis dans cette
classe renversé nous appliquons la
devise bien connue de tous et de toutes
la meilleure façon d'apprendre c'est
d'enseigner
alors chers étudiants devenait les
professeurs j'ai donc 40 professeurs
dans la classe et il n'y a plus qu'un
seul élève finalement tester ce que vous
produisez sur le meilleur élève de la
classe
le rêve pour un enseignant 100% de la
promo constitué du meilleur élève en
génétique - les étudiants construisent
le court il le dispense ils font leurs
explications tableau et moi je pose des
questions finalement aujourd'hui
depuis cinq ans dans ma classe il n'y en
a plus qu'un seul qui rentre chez lui
avec des devoirs à la maison
c'est moi plus de copies à corriger
juste des exercices à préparer au cas où
je me ferais interrogé le lendemain
matin et noter les étudiants organisent
l'examen prépare les questions montrent
les barèmes si vous leur posez la
question est-ce difficile d'interroger
un profil vous dise oui il faut
connaître le court puis pour connaître
le court il faut savoir construire des
barres n et lorsque le prof vous répond
il faut être capable de le corriger
donc une très bonne méthode en vous
racontant tout cela il me revient en
tête
deux anecdotes deux anecdotes
particulières qui permettent de
comprendre pourquoi les entreprises
finalement les managers des directeurs
sont intéressés par ces innovations
pédagogiques
la première anecdote est celle de la
bactérie à deux chromosomes
je me souviens très bien c'était un
mercredi matin j'écoutais l'un d'entre
eux avec son ami expliqué au tableau le
fonctionnement d'une bactérie elle était
magnifique bien dessinée est tout ce qu
il expliqué était particulièrement juste
presque aucune erreur une seule chose me
perturber il y avait dans sa bactérie
deux chromosomes circulaire or tout le
monde le sait vous comme moi il n'ya
qu'un seul chromosome dans une bactérie
après tout je suis l'expert donc je le
laisse finir son explication et je lui
dis j'ai une question pourquoi il ya
deux chromosomes dans ta bactéries il me
répond c'est comme ça il n'y a pas
d'explication
alors j'essaye de l'aider tout en
essayant de lui faire comprendre qu'il
avait fait une erreur et je lui dis ah
je crois que je sais pourquoi cette
bactérie en fait qui n'a qu'un seul
chromosome est en train de se diviser et
pour se diviser
elle doit dupliquer son chromosome en
deux et lorsqu'elle aura deux
chromosomes et pourra donner deux
bactéries
donc j'ai compris et lui de me répondre
mais pas du tout regardez bien il est un
grand et un petit chromosome donc ce
n'est pas possible
élémentaire mon cher professeur alors là
je ne sais plus quoi lui dire et tout
d'un coup
sa collègue avec l'ordinateur en main me
dit monsieur le professeur
sachez que publication à l'appui que
récemment au texas dans l'université de
houston
une équipe de chercheurs américains a
montré que chez 32 souches de l'espèce
au bac terre sphéroïde s on avait deux
chromosomes un grand et un petit
deux jours plus tard dans mon amphi de
médecine devant mes 500 étudiants qui
prennent des notes mot-à-mot pour
préparer le concours je leur dit d'un
ton assuré
vous savez tous que les bactéries n'ont
qu'un seul chromosome et bien sachez et
peu de gens le savent
qu'une équipe américaine récemment au
texas dans l'université de houston a
montré que chez 32 souche d'euros de
batère stéroïdes s il y avait deux
chromosomes un grand et un petit là au
premier rang jean tanus tuant qui dit à
son collègue war le prof quelle culture
et son camarade de classe lui répondant
c'est normal c'est un chercheur la
deuxième anecdote est celle de
l'étudiant qui pensaient ne rien savoir
je me souviens aussi très bien c'était
la première séance je venais d'expliquer
le principe de la méthode est là un
étudiant vient vers moi et me dit vous
savez monsieur votre méthode de classe
renversé me paraît vraiment intéressante
mais pour moi et mes cinq camarades
ça va être très compliqué ça fait 2 à 3
ans que nous n'avons plus fait de
biologie alors un chapitre où un
programme qui parle de réplication
transcription régulation mutation ça va
être quasiment mission impossible
deux mois plus tard alors que j'avais
répartit ses cinq étudiants dans cinq
équipes différentes
je vois mon étudiant au tableau devant
un schéma presque aussi grand que lui
donnait des tas d'explications à
certains de ses collègues
je m'approche de lui le regarde il se
retourne et me dire qu'y at il
non non rien que fais tu vous le voyez
bien j'explique la régulation de l'eau
père au lactose chez une bactérie en
manque de glucose et comme vous le
remarquez sur ce schéma le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas de glucose permet aux
répresseur lactose d'être inhibé donc de
ne pas se fixer sur l'opérateur près du
moc promoteurs est de permettre la
synthèse de la bêta galec torride a
envie nécessaires à la digestion du
lactose pour produire du glucose
élémentaire mon cher professeur
alors là je le regarde étonné il
remarque mon étonnement il me dit
pourquoi c c'est faux il ya des erreurs
non non presque tout est bon mais ce
n'est pas toi qui me disait il ya peu de
temps que tu ne savais pas ce qu'était
une molécule d'adr et là tu en train de
m'expliquer la régulation d'un gène de
bactéries et lui il me répondre mais
monsieur je ne sais toujours pas ce
qu'est molécule adn
mais par contre ce mécanisme c'est top
génial j'ai vraiment envie de savoir
maintenant ces deux anecdotes parmi tant
d'autres montre que l'innovation
pédagogique peut intéresser aussi au
delà de la classe que les entreprises se
posent des questions quant à ses
méthodes de classe inversée classe
renversé travail collaboratif
l'anecdote de la bactérie à deux
chromosomes montre que l'on peut
toujours apprendre des autres même des
non experts qu'il faut savoir dire à ses
étudiants parfois je ne sais pas les
écouter travailler ensemble il faut leur
faire confiance
c'est une question de confiance
confiance dans les étudiants que les
étudiants aient confiance en leurs
professeurs mais aussi que les étudiants
aient confiance entre eux pour
travailler de manière collective
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que la meilleure
façon d'apprendre c'est est d'enseigner
je pense aujourd'hui que la meilleure
façon d'enseigner c'est aussi
d'apprendre essayer d'apprendre des
autres de changer un peu de posture
l'anecdote de l'étudiant qui pensaient
ne rien savoir nous montre que chacun
peut apprendre à sa vitesse et
travailler en complémentarité avec les
autres faire du coworking du travail
collaboratif
après tout ce qui compte c'est le
résultat collectif de l'équipe et pas
forcément le résultat individuel
il faut savoir accepter de perdre du
temps perdre du temps parfois c'est en
gagner je repense à ces étudiants et je
me dis si le premier jour je lui avais
dit ne t'en fais pas je vais te remettre
à niveau et après 10 à 12 heures de
cours de biologie moléculaire tu seras
capable de comprendre ce que font les
autres
peut-être que je l'aurais écoeurait or
là il a eu envie d'aller plus loin dans
l'acquisition de ses connaissances
alors une salle de classe avec 40
professeurs et un seul élève est ce
raisonnable audacieux je ne sais pas
innovant tout au moins innovant si l'on
accepte de prendre des risques de sortir
de sa position de confort entre 10
d'accepter d'aller vers les étudiants de
travailler avec eux de manière
différente et de produire finalement de
la connaissance de la partager d'une
autre manière qui ne remplacent pas les
cours académiques mais qui est
complémentaire travailler de manière
différente être innovant en pédagogie la
pédagogie intéressant d'ailleurs de
savoir que dans l'antiquité le pédagogue
n'était pas un prof pédagogie marcher à
côté de l'enfant
le pédagogue dans l'antiquité était un
esclave sans connaissance particulière
qui accompagné l'enfant du maître à
l'école où il apprenait ses leçons du
maître l'autre puis le pédagogue ramener
l'enfant à la maison peut-être lui
portant son cartable de l'époque
peut-être le protégeant sur le chemin
peut-être les dents faire ses devoirs
la pédagogie c'est de l'accompagnement
pas étonnant que ça intéresse aussi les
entreprises les ressources humaines et
pas uniquement le monde de l'école alors
oubliez un peu cette histoire de classe
inversée renversé et penser à
l'entreprise à l'institution à
l'association peut-être dans laquelle
vous travaillez et l audacieuse hostel
prendre des risques quand je parle de
l'école pensez-vous à l'entreprise quand
je parle du professeur de l'expert
pensez vous au directeur aux managers et
quand je parle de l'élève de l'étudiant
pensez vous aux collègues de travail aux
clients aux fournisseurs la pédagogie
c'est une affaire d'entreprise comme une
affaire d'éducation
on pourrait imaginer non pas des
entreprises inversé ou renverser mais
tout simplement au départ une réunion
inversée un comité de direction renversé
40 directeur 40 directrice et un seul
collaborateur un seul ouvrier un seul
technicien osé prendre des risques le
monde de l'éducation et celui de
l'entreprise ne sont pas si différents
le monde de l'éducation et de plus en
plus professionnalisant celui de
l'entreprise est apprenants ils ont donc
vocation à se croiser à s'inspirer
mutuellement
donc pas étonnant que la classe renversé
intéresse aussi le monde dit du travail
alors demain matin ou la semaine
prochaine
chacun chacune d'entre vous lorsque vous
irez travailler quel que soit l'endroit
pmi pme entreprises institutions
associations
pourquoi pas l'école repenser à ce prof
un peu bizarre au milieu de ces
étudiants et dites vous et pourquoi pas
moi aussi un moment
l'espace d'un instant devenir un peu
renversant
[Applaudissements]